Can we get fired
if you are on sick leave too often ?
There are several cases where
your employer can dismiss you
despite your sick leave
and I'll explain it in detail in this video.
First,
your employer may dismiss you for 1 reason
disciplinary and that even if you are on sick leave.
This is the case if you have made 1 mistake
before you stop.
2nd case,
your employer may dismiss you
for economic reasons.
Even if you are on sick leave,
you can have 1 economic layoff.
3rd case,
your employer may dismiss you
for y 1 professional aptitude.
This is the case if you are no longer able to resume
your job
or for example if your occupational physician
is opposed to the resumption of this job,
or if
your employer
is not able to offer you 1 job
adapted to your health condition,
or in case you yourself have refused
arranged employment.
The last possible case,
is when there is
of the company's operations.
This is especially the case if you chain yourself
sick leave and that your
employer cannot organize properly.
But be careful,
3 conditions must be
so that your employer can fire you
for this reason.
First,
it is if you
really disrupt the proper functioning
of the company,
secondly,
it is so
employer is forced to replace you in a manner
definitively and thirdly,
is if your sick leave is not related to it.
1 possible failure of the employer.